hey guys I'm off the grid for August and
here's fake Native American Elizabeth
Warren being a really really horrible
person on that note Senator I want you
to listen to One reaction from a small
business owner who thinks that he has
played by the rules his name is Brian
lonsberry
we have done the sacrifices the no
vacations and no out to eat and now I'm
on the other side the reason it upsets
me so much is are we setting a good
example it's a little upsetting that
we kept pain and struggled and through
everything and then other people just
gave up and quit and and I wasn't raised
to to quit
what do you say to Brian and others who
say that this is really not fair that
the student loan is just one kind of
debt and there are other people who
don't have that but have other struggles
that the government isn't helping them
with
I think a lot about fairness and I think
about how education debt is different
from other debt I look at it this way I
wanted to be a public school teacher
from the time I was in second grade my
daddy ended up as a janitor and there
was no money for me to go to college
but I found a public university that
cost fifty dollars a semester and for a
price I could pay for on a part-time
waitressing job I finished a four-year
diploma I became a special education
teacher and it opened a million doors
for me that opportunity is not out there
today for any of our kids our public
education system is no longer creating
opportunities for kids like me and other
kids whose families can't afford to
write a check instead we're saying to
these young people you've got to get an
education but we are going to wrap the
the chains of debt around you and for
many you're going to be paying it for
decades into the future including
getting Social Security checks garnished
that's not the America we want well I'm
not sure you want to be an America of
opportunity yeah but I'm not sure that
this
relieving this amount of debt changes
the cost of college cost of college is
still exorbitant well
look part of what it does is it deals
with the debt has been built up because
the cost of college has gone up because
taxpayers have made fewer investments in
our public colleges and universities
because for-profit colleges have swooped
in and figured out that they can cheat a
lot of students we have a lot of
problems in the whole system the
president has done what he can do with
the tool in front of him